major development tonight concerning
presidential advisor and son-in-law
Jared Kushner chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge is in
Washington to tell us what it is and why
it's so important could even Catherine
well thank you Brett and good evening
Fox News confirms through multiple
sources that the president's son-in-law
Jared Kushner recently received his full
security clearance late today his lawyer
said Kushner spoke to the special
counsel pardon me Robert Muller last
month for seven hours addressing all
topics adding his clearance was handled
by the book it happened in the normal
course it happened the way it happens
for thousands of people it goes too
initially the Bureau who does a
background investigation it takes a lot
of time it then gets prais'd through
various agencies it gets to the White
House there's a special office that does
security measures they're all career
people there was nobody in the political
process
Kershner had been working off an interim
security clearance as he pursued foreign
policy issues on behalf of the president
in February the interim clearance was
downgraded after chief of staff John
Kelly issued new rules and Kushner's
security investigation had not been
completed with the Russia investigation
looming over the White House the
clearance became a major media story
becoming a distraction given all the
controversies that he did at the center
of in recent days Jared stille about
you'd member of the administration and
he's going to continue to focus on the
work that he's been doing and we're
gonna continue pushing forward on that
front as well a former intelligence
community official and Inspector General
described the decision as a very
significant one given the ongoing Millar
probe because he said the matter would
have been reviewed and approved at the
highest levels of the FBI the official
said access to classified materials no
matter what level of clearance would
only happen if there were no outstanding
counterintelligence concerns Bret
oneness with the panel captain thank you